improve your go programming skills by
developing three different projects in
this go course experience developer Akil
Sharma will teach you how to build a
website Health Checker a program to
encrypt text and a program to encrypt
files hey guys in this video we're
building three awesome projects with
goang now these are beginner friendly
projects and awesome additions to your
portfolio in case you're applying for a
goang job in the first project we're
going to be building a goang health
Checker where we'll check the health of
a website so you'll just have to enter
the domain name of a website and you'll
come to know if it's live or it's down
the second project is about encrypting
files so we'll start with the PNG file
and we'll encrypt it we'll try to access
it without the password and then we'll
access it with the password to see how
encryption works the third project is
about encrypting a string with goang so
all these three projects you learn quite
a bit a lot of goang so if you have
basic goang skills you'll be able to
refine your skills and build on top of
that not knowledge so let's get started
hey guys welcome back in today's video
we're building a very simple project
we're going to build a goang project
which checks if a website is running or
it's down and accordingly we'll show the
appropriate message in the terminal
saying the website is up or running or
it's down or not running right and
you'll find these kind of projects uh
very easily on Google if you go and if
you check if the is the website on there
many projects like these and they
basically run it free of cost but then
they show ads so if you want to do that
you can do that as well but it's just a
great project to build and to basically
practice your goang skills right uh now
this project is going to be a part of
the uh goang playlist goang Project
Playlist so in my YouTube If you go to
the playlist there's a goang playlist it
right now it has 46 projects so I have
called it the 46 killer goang projects
playlist but then the number keeps Chang
changing so once I put this video it'll
be like 47 goang projects right so
depending on when you watch this video
the number would have changed but then
you know it's important to know that
that playlist exists and you can and
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
arrange those projects in the increasing
level of difficulty and this project
since it's very small and very simple
we'll place it towards the beginning of
that playlist even though I'm releasing
it quite at the end but I'm going to
actually position it towards the
beginning of of the playlist okay so
with that out of the way we can get
started I'll show you a couple of
diagrams just to help you visualize what
your building uh and then we'll just go
ahead and build it all right now just
before we get started I just want to
tell you that a very common name for
this project that we're building is
called the health Checker right so for
any project that you're building you
might also want to create a health
Checker microservice in case you don't
want to launch this as your own project
on the internet completely fine uh but
you can but usually when people build
let's say a project and then they
usually build a microservice which
checks health of their own
project so with with the project that we
building you could do that like check
the health of your own project or you
could check the health of any website
that's up or down you can check that
state status of that website all right
now we can get started so now I think
you can see my
screen here uh we've just represented
what we'll be doing in our code so we'll
have a main.go file which will have the
main function and all we doing is
importing the CLI package so it could be
any CLI package like you could be using
something like uh Cobra or something
like that but I'll be using something
very small and basic in this project
because this project is small right and
um we'll be passing two things we'll be
making use of two things one is Flags so
we'll set two flags which is the domain
and the port and the action for the CLI
tool tool would be to call the check
function okay the check function is is
going to be defined in a file called
check. go it's going to accept
destination and Port because that's what
we'll send from here to this function
destination and port and the whole
business logic here or the Crux of the
entire program is the dial timeout
function this function you get in this
package called net the net package very
popular package to work with uh web web
related things in goang right so we'll
use D dial time out package and finally
we will return the status of the website
whether it's up or down so that's the
entire business logic here in the in the
project so now let's go ahead create a
new project and get
started all right so now we'll start
building our project everything that
I'll be showing you in this video is
already there in my GitHub account so
make sure you check out Akil Sharma 90
which is my username on GitHub all the
projects are there check out the code in
case you get stuck somewhere we just
create a new directory called go health
check
YT so we'll CD into
it and what we'll do is we will um go
mod in
it and I'll just give it my
username go health check right okay so
now you can see the go mod file already
has been created and we will just open
up our vs fold and check out that yeah
everything looks all right now I have
decided upon the uh package that I'll be
using it's CLI version two and I found
it on this uh project on this profile
called yourf This is a common package
it's very very light so if you're not
building something huge like a proper CI
tool I recommend using something like
this something very light like this
there thousands of packages like these
by the way but if you're building
something serious then obviously Cobra
CLI is is the way to go anyways now
we'll create two files as you know one
is the main.go
file and the other is our check. go file
okay in the main. go
file we will do the regular stuff
package name import the import
statements and all of that and in the
import I want to put this package so
that it's clear that we're going to use
it and then you have your fun
main that's how you start that's the
most important part in your main main.
go file obviously and I'm going to go
ahead and create an uh create app which
is basically C.A right CLI being the
package that I'm
using and this helps to create a
complete CLI tool where I can give it a
name I can show how the tool is used I
can give in the flags we've already
talked about the flags and I can talk
about the action it's supposed to have
happen when
the you know the right commands are or
the right yeah the right commands are
given what's the action that's supposed
to
happen all
right
[Music]
so yeah now for for the name what we'll
say is we'll say let's call
it health checker
and the usage let's usage basically
basic text of how this product is going
to be useful say tiny
tool that
checks whether a
website is running or it's
down and then there are the flags so CLI
do
flag
okay and here you have the name which is
domain
aliases
[Music]
string
D and the usage which is the this is
where you'll enter the domain name like
for example google.com that's the domain
name to check whether it's up or down so
that's domain and it's obviously it's
required so we say required is true
without this there's no point of the app
if if you don't have this
right all right so uh in the flags
there's one more flag that we going to
have which is the c. string flag it's
going to be name will
be
Port Al
s's string
B
Visage port number to
check and
required
false
right now for the
action you're going to have c.
context
and we might return an
error and let's define the port which is
C do
string and the
port and if c.
string and
Port is null which is
empty then the port will be 80 right so
what's happening here which is standard
basically whenever you check anything
you're checking on Port 80 which is like
the most common Port right where the uh
the hand check would happen anyways but
let's say um you but you can you can say
any port you can mention any port here
but if you have not mentioned any port
here the default Port which is 80 which
is the one that that's always checked
that's the one that will be um set right
for the port variable and then you have
status is equal to check so this is the
check function I was talking about which
which we will create in the other file
called the check.of file and you are
checking the domain and the port so we
sending two things to the check function
which is domain and the port which is
what I had shown you in the
diagram
and we're going to print the
status and return ma for the error if
everything go
well here we'll say
error equal to app.
run okay so you say app which you just
created the whole app using the CLI uh
package and you're going to say app.run
passing in the OS arguments and you're
also handling the error so if there is
an error you can do something about it
if the error is not equal to n that
means the error is there it's say log
dot fatal and you'll print out the
error all
right and now we can work on the other
file which is check. go so now we're
going to go ahead and create the check.
go file before that what I'll do is I'll
just say go mod Ty just to create the go
s
file there seems to be some problem
we'll fix fix it no
problem so right now let's just create
the check. go file okay so say package
main also this part of package main only
not creating a separate
package and
here uh there are a few more packages
that I've used actually like fmt and all
those and somehow they've not come up so
usually when I save the files they come
up like my plugins are not working I
think right now I'll just copy and paste
them on my own
anyways all right so here also I'll need
some packages I'll just say fmt time and
net the most important one obviously
here is the net package you know that
because the net package has the um dial
timeout function that we'll use to
actually check the status of the website
so we'll say fun
check
destination it's a string and Port which
is a string and return the string string
being the status so we return the status
from the check
function so here we'll say
address equal
to
destination
Plus Port right destination being the
domain name and Port being the port that
you pass in or or
even um Port 80 which is the default
right so we'll say for the duration
of 5
Seconds is a time
out so within 5 seconds if you get a
response back from the website that
means the website is on otherwise it's
not okay this is the main part which is
we're using the net package and the dial
timeout
function we need to send in the address
which is basically the destination the
port both combined with the timeout
which is 5 seconds in our
case and let's create a variable called
status which is the one that we're going
to return from this
function and here this error that we
have which
is we're checking we'll have to now
check for that error so we'll say if
error is not equal to nil means there is
some error then we'll say status would
be fmt dot Sprint
F
down website is not reachable so to
print out the name of the website star V
sorry percentage V is unreachable the
website is not
reachable and you
can print out the error for percentage
three and here the actual variables
which is destination
and the error all
right
else we will say status we FMP do
printf and we
say
up
percentage V
that's the basically
the website is
reachable and then we'll print out
from which address we
tried
to which
address that means the
destination comma
[Music]
connection
dot local address right so your
connection variable will have a copy of
local address the address at your end
which is making the conect the the
request and the remote address basically
the website and the port that you had
mentioned just above and
finally when your the status okay so all
okay here I
think to get rid of the error just
remove this quickly and let goang do it
for you so just say go mod tid it'll get
all the
packages right that you're supposed to
have and it'll also generate the go. sum
file for you here in the main. go file
there's an issue because there's a small
spelling mistake it should have been
adss and uh but I see one more error so
me quickly
check yeah the other thing is that
there's another spelling mistake here
it's
CLI all right so
hopefully everything should be fine now
but I still see one more
error all right
so uh yeah that's one more issue which
is spelling of name is wrong I'll just
save it everything seems fine now to
me uh here so by flag you know what you
mean by flag is that when we run this uh
tool now we'll have
to pass the flag so let me actually show
you how to do it so we'll say go run do
minus minus domain which which is the
flag now in our case and it could be
tel.com
so it's saying it's reachable right so
if you
say
google.com
and
amazon.com yeah so all the websites are
up at the moment all of them are
reachable all right so that was our
simple yet effective tool that we've
built
and we've done we've done quite a bit in
this
tutorial uh it's a very very tiny tool
but then a lot of Concepts have been
used here so I hope you've learned quite
a bit thank you so much for watching do
make sure you watch all the other
projects in this series because there so
much to learn right and thank you so
much for watching and do subscribe hey
hey hey in today's video we are
encrypting files with goang so in my
root directory of this project I have
the img.png file which I'm going to now
encrypt so as you can see I can I can
see the file now right but if I encrypt
it so I'll say go
run
encrypt uh and I'll say img.png which is
the name of the file I want to encrypt
and I'll enter some password it'll
confirm the password and it'll encrypt
it for me and say it'll say file
successfully protected and now as you
can see I can't see it anymore I can't
see the file anymore but now if I go and
if I just decrypt the same
file it will ask me to enter the
password it will say file successfully
decrypted and now again sorry now again
I can see the image awesome
right so how is this happening so let me
let me take you through it so in the
beginning what will happen is we will
accept the um r arguments from user
which is uh the basically the file the
path to the file or the file name we'll
validate if the file even exists or not
and we'll also ask the user for the
password and we'll validate the password
in the sense if both the passwords match
this is for the encryption part right
we'll check if both the passwords match
password one and password two then we'll
encrypt the file and then for decrypt
we'll again check the password after
getting the password we check the
password okay so it's really
straightforward for for from a 10,000 ft
perspective this is what's happening
just getting arguments from the user
validating the file getting the password
from the user and cing the file by
validating the password and then
decrypting the file with the same
password that's what's happening but if
you look uh more if you look a bit
deeper then you have two parts
encryption and decryption in the
encryption part uh we follow multiple
steps so we first check for the source
file we open that source file the one
with the plain text which was our
img.png and and then we'll re read that
plain text now it could be the data from
the PNG or it could be a text file right
whatever it is it's basically plain data
from the source file then we'll create
an empty uh variable called a nuns this
will be 12 bits or 12 bytes in our in
our case and we'll create we'll
randomize it so we'll create a random
basically 12 byte uh variable we because
we want to use it later on so firstly
you have the password that we'll use to
encrypt the file right so the the
password and then there's something
called as the length in the sense what
do you want to get after running a
derivation function so we'll basically
be running a password based derivation
function I'll talk more about it the
first thing you need is a password the
next thing you need is the bip length in
our case will be 32 then the algorithm
with which we want to encrypt it and the
number of iterations in our case it will
be like some somewhere around 4,000
iterations iterations basically make it
more difficult for the party that wants
to uh hack this or or break the
encryption just makes it more difficult
for them okay okay so uh with the
password based key derivation function
this is a function in which a key will
be generated from the password so we'll
take in the password and we'll add in a
few different things as you can see and
we'll get a key and this can be used as
an encryption key or the hash value so
we basically just hashing the password
now this is very similar to how you um
take the users's password you hash it
and then you store in the database right
because you don't want to store the
passwords directly in the database
because otherwise people can steal or
get access to the database steal all the
password right so you always hash the
passwords with some salt and that's
what's happening here right so uh this
is the salt in this case the nuns so
with the password based key dation
function you get something called as a
derived key now the derived key we'll
run it past uh AES or Advanced
encryption standard this will give us
some solid encryption abilities after
after getting the key from the password
and we'll and this by by running it
through the a a cipher we'll get
something called as a cyer for block and
that again we'll run from uh through
something called as the uh galwa counter
mode now this is spelled as g l o i s
but I think this is like a French word
so you say gal galwa or something like
that I'm not French so I have no idea so
it's the GCM I call it the GCM galwa
cter whatever blah blah blah but GCM
basically right and GCM gives you more
encryption with data Integrity checks
now GCM generates a tag which is
appended to the C Cipher text at the end
and this tag is used to verify the
Integrity upon data encryption now you
had some data you encrypted it but then
how do you know that the data that you
got back is actually the correct data
and that's why we using GCM because that
gives us the tag to verify the Integrity
of of the data upon decryption and GCM
uses AES so we as as you know we have
already used AES before it uses AES to
encrypt the plain text this operates in
a counter mode and hence the name and
and generates a stream of encrypted
blocks that's what GCM does finally we
use this uh function called AES GCM
which AES GCM is what you get so you
already had the AES Cipher which is the
ciper block then you run it through GCM
you get AES GCM and you run this
function called AES GCM do seal this is
the main function now this is uh just to
use this function we had to do all of
this basically all of this part because
we wanted to run this function called
the seal function and the seal function
is what takes the plain text from our
file from our IMG file or any other file
and convert it into Cipher text and it
then creates a source file for encrypted
data and we write Cipher text to the new
source file so the the file in our case
Remains the Same but then again we have
to create the source file for the
incryptor and write the cipher text
Cipher text is basically text that we
can't then access right so that'll be
written to the source file so that's the
encryption now let's go over the
decryption for the decryption it's very
very similar uh we'll check for the
encrypted file so here we were checking
for the source file that had to be
encrypted and now we'll be checking for
the encrypted file because uh to our
program we will be saying that hey this
is the encrypted file please decrypt it
for me so we'll check for the encrypted
file we'll open that file we'll read the
cipher text from the enced file right
the text that we can't open in our IDE
but it still can be read from our
function now to convert the cipher text
into uh regular plane text we have to
again run the password based key
activation function so we'll have to
have the same password which we used to
enp we you have to have the same
password to decrypt uh decrypt it as
well same bite length same algorithm sh
one and the number of itation should
also be the same and then the nuns uh as
you remember we created a nuns here a
randomized nuns and uh the the GCM
basically uh appended the nuns to the
cipher text and exactly that's what we
want we want to get the nuns from here
uh which will be at the end so the the
last 12 digits of the encrypted file
will have the nuns you want access to
that so all of these uh five things
we'll pass to the password based key
derivation function we'll get the
derived key again the same thing as
Cipher we'll get the cipher block GCM
you'll get a GCM now we did again we did
all of this so this was important
obviously you know that you have to use
SOL to Hash the password this is perfect
but these extra steps we only did
because we wanted to use this aesg cm.
openen function which takes in the
cipher text to this function without the
NS obviously and gets you back the plain
text now the pl text is what you will
write again to a file which will have
the decrypted data or the other PL text
and that's the one that you will write
back to the file and that's how you'll
be able to read the file again so that's
what's happening in your encryption and
decryption so in our program in the code
what we'll need to have is we'll need to
um do all of this like the whole entire
Logic for the encrypt function and the
entire Logic for the decryption function
and I'll keep opening this diagram again
and again in between just so that we
able to refer it while we are writing
the code but the program also needs to
do all of this so we'll the way I'm
thinking of it is that I'll need one
file which will have the encryption
decryption functions and I'll need one
file which is the main.go file which
will will have all of this thing which
will print out stuff to the terminal and
accept uh values from the user from the
terminal so all of that logic I'll put
in main.go file okay so now we can start
writing our code now before we start
writing our code just want to tell you
that um on my channel this particular
video that we creating right now will
show up in the 48 killer goang project
Series so this is a playlist which
basically is uh which has 48 projects
now but I'll add this one so it'll be 49
projects and um this playlist right is
in the order of difficulty so we have
smaller uh simpler programs earlier and
then more difficult programs later on
this will be somewhere in the middle
it's not or somewhere towards the end
but not at the complete end because this
is not very difficult to build what we
building today today uh so um just make
sure you you go through all the videos
in this playlist and you build them one
by one and once you've done that you
will no goang better than more better
than 90% of the people or 99% of the
people actually out there because I mean
uh how many people do you know who build
like 50 50 projects with goang right not
many so this will seriously give you an
edge if you build all the projects in
this playlist all
right and and uh I also wanted to tell
you one more thing that if you go to my
channel uh you get access to this
Discord link here as you can see this is
the Discord link for this community out
here which is uh where we discuss a lot
of stuff around golang and we share our
learnings what we've been learning today
uh we have a lot of um like forums where
we uh discuss issues uh that we that
you're facing blah blah blah so lot lot
of stuff here so uh a lot of cool
discussions happening so make sure sure
you join this because uh I mean if you
want to learn if you want to learn goang
this is the right place to be this is
the right Community to be at all right
because I'm here quite a lot as you can
see it's always open on my browser these
days so I'm always there replying to
messages all right so uh I have now
talked through all the things that I
wanted to talk through so now is the
time to start building the project what
I'll now do is I'll create a
new uh directory
called go file
encryption by the way this program this
project already exists on my GitHub so
in case uh you are are already following
me on GitHub uh you will see this
program there the F encryption one um in
case I don't put the link to this
project in my description of this video
please know that my GitHub is Akil
Sharma 90 ail s RMA 90 the project is
there in case you get stuck somewhere um
you can access the code you can look at
the code and build along with me all
right so here I will CD into it I will
CD into go file encryption and we will
say go mod in
it
github.com
sharma9
SL code file
encryption
this creates a um go. mod file for us
which will have the list of all our
dependencies and I'll just go ahead and
open this up in my code
infl here I'll just create a um main.go
file and I'll create a folder for file
Crypt and there will be a file called
filecrypt okay now I told you that I'll
divide the logic into two different
parts one will be the uh interfacing
with the user part and the other will be
the actual encryption and decryption so
let's talk about the part where we'll
accept user values so we first start
with sorry package main not M we start
with package main all right and there
will obviously be Funk main which is
from so main is the most important file
main. go is the most important file
which is obviously the main package
again and then it has the main function
which is where the uh program begins
from or Origins everything starts from
here and then this is why from this
function we have to call all the other
functions this is like the root or the
source of everything then there will be
an import statement here and I'll import
multiple um packages in a while so
firstly I want to check if the length of
the arguments now to to work with
arguments to print out messages to the
CLI we could use something like Cobra
which is a CLI tool and I have and I
already have uh projects with that I
think uh that's very commonly used in
goang as you know Cobra uh we're not
using it here because we have like very
few operations and we can do that uh on
our own we don't need to import a
complete Library just to print out stuff
to the terminal and to work with some
arguments right and uh here we're just
checking of the length of the arguments
is less than two if it is less than two
then we'll print
help and print help will basically print
out uh so there's a function called
print help it's print help which
basically tells the user and how to
actually use this uh project so if he's
not if the user user is not uh entering
let's say encrypt or decrypt and the
name of the file that means it doesn't
know how to use this function right so
you'll just print help out in that
scenario and the other thing is function
equal to OS do ARS
one and we'll
switch
function so what do you want to do so do
you want
help if you want help we'll just print
help we'll just call the print help
function if you want to
encrypt we will call the encrypt handle
decrypt you will call the
decrypt handle
function and then there is
a
default which
is run
encrypt to encrypt a file and TP to TP
right just telling the user that hey
please run encrypt to encrypt the file
and decrypt to decrypt the
file okay
so that is our main function now as you
know we're calling three functions from
the main function which is the print
help encrypt handle and decrypt handle
so we're going to call we create all
those
functions uh so we have the we'll have
the
encrypt handle
function and we have
the
decrypt hand
function
there are three more functions that
we'll need in the encrypt handle there
is the um get
password to get the password from the
user and then we have the
validate
uh so we have the get password function
we have the validate file and validate
password
functions so let me create
those
password and
frun
validate validate
file okay so and the print help print
help is going to be very straightforward
so I'll just go ahead and copy and paste
actually don't have to write this whole
thing on your own so this is basically
saying file encryption simple file
encryption for your day-to-day needs uh
which is the name of the program and
then what it does and then showing you
usage that you can go run and uh when we
say dot basically means it runs all the
files in uh at the root which is our
main.go and also our file. cp. go uh
folder package and it'll basically uh
you want to pass the path to your file
in our case we'll just say img.png which
will be a file that I'll copy and paste
here you can copy and paste any file
here I'm just using this apple file here
and then you have the commands the
commands like encrypt decrypt and help
you'll have three commands encrypt will
encrypt a file with a given password
decrypt tries to decp a file using a
password and help which displays the
help text which is uh this particular
function gets called
there now for the encrypt handle which
is the most important one uh sorry the
encrypt and decrypt actually are both uh
really important because that's the
logic main logic so here we'll check if
OS do if
the length of os. ARS is less than three
that means uh you have written you have
written that uh you want to run the
program and you want to encrypt but
you've not passed
the uh
the pass the file right so it's argument
sesson three then you will print
Ln you will print
out missing the part to
five for more info
run
um so encrypt we say from the help
command
all right and
os. exit
Z if everything is all right then what
you want to do is you want to get the
arguments or which is basically the uh
arguments at the second index which is
the third
argument uh which in our case is the
part of the file you want to get it in
this variable called file and you want
to Val validate so if not validate
file and you pass the file
there and we'll just
Panic file not
found so what happens in the validate
file function and this gets called it
basically it takes in the file which is
string and it passes back Boolean which
is that's how we checking it it here you
know true or false this exclamation
helps us check that so if it's not uh
valid then we say file not found okay
and how does it return the Boolean it's
basically using the os. stat function on
the
file and saying
if ederal
to OS do is
not exist
return false if it doesn't exist return
false if it exists return
true that's how we're checking for it
out here so for the encrypt part we have
checked
um the validity of the file and not
found now the next step is to ask for
the password so we'll say password is
equal to
get password right so we already have
the get password function so what is do
it do it
Returns the
password which is a slice of
bites and how does it accept the
password it says first it prints out
enter
password then it's going to use the
terminal terminal package to
read the
password and going to capture that
in the
password
variable so when you if you remember
when we were encrypting the file we
didn't only just accept the password we
also asked the user for the confirm
password as in confirm this password so
you want to print that out as well so
you're going to
say
sln
confirm
password and we want to
again read the
password okay and this will be password
to and here is where we will validate if
the password one and password two are
the same they're matching so we'll say
if not
validate password which will will pass
password one and password two basically
this function the validate password
function should return back to us a
Boolean and here we say fmt do
print
passwords do not match pleas try again
turn get password if the password don't
match we want this function the get
password function to be called again and
again Ask the pass uh the user password
so if everything went well we just want
to return the password from here which
is a slice of bites okay now in the
validate password function let's come
here so it's going to accept something
called as password one which is a slice
of bites and password two which is again
a slash of ptes return back a
bilion and in here you want to check if
the bytes are equal if everything is
equal in password one and password
two it's not equal
return false if it's equal return
true that that's our return uh validate
password function which got called here
and we'll go back now to our encrypt
handle so after
calling the uh the get password
function we
will say fmt do print Len and inform the
user that hey we've started
encrypting the file so we say
encrypting and we'll use the file Crypt
package the file Crypt package is our
own we'll create the file Crypt package
out here so we say file Crypt do encrypt
because we'll have the encrypt function
we'll pass it the file and the password
and we'll print out FM do print Len
you'll
say file
success
detected so that's our encrypt handy
function now in the decrypt handle
function we will again check the same
thing which is this like has he given us
the file uh the part of the file if not
we want to exit and we want to then
validate the file
again and we want to ask the user for
this password so we say do
print enter
password and we want to say
password terminal. read
password and after taking the password
we'll just print out instead of
encrypting we'll just print out
decrypting and instead of encrypt file
the uh function encrypt function we'll
just call the decrypt function passing
the file and password and here instead
of protected we'll just say
decrypted so we have the encrypt handle
and decrypt handle functions perfect
clearly get password validate password
validate file and CP handle print help
and name now in the import statement we
should have
um all
the
files which file Crypt is my own package
which I'll get from here the xterm
package is the one that we're using here
term uh the one that we're getting to to
using to read the password and then we
have byes fmtn okay so that's how it is
now I can already see some issues and
errors and some of them should go away
once I've completed my file crypt.of
file but then there will be many others
that we fixed not a
problem and now let's go ahead and start
working on our file crypt.of file so
starting with the filecrypt
Dogo this package is going to be called
filecrypt and we'll import some packages
of
course then we have two functions one is
the encrypt function as you
know and the other is going to the
decrypt
function
okay because from here we are calling
the encrypt and the decrypt
functions so in the encrypt handle and
decrypt handle respectively you call the
encrypt function from file Crypt and the
decrypt function from filecrypt those
are the ones that we working on at the
moment so in the E encrypt function you
take in the source which is string and
the password which
is
bite it's a slice of
bytes
okay so now this uh Source in our case
is the file
right because if you check here we're
sending the file and the password so
file and the password right so for the
file we want to
check if the
file let me actually open up the browser
and show you the diagram again and we'll
follow the exact same
steps so here it is we'll check for the
source open the source file read read PL
text from the source file create an
empty nuns randomize nuns Let's do let's
do those
steps so first is os. stat
then the
source. is not
exist and if it doesn't exist we are
just going to return an
[Music]
error
so first we checked for the
file now we'll open up that file so
we'll say os.
open
source and we'll capture that or store
that in source
file and if error is not equal to
n
panic
errors at the end of this program when
this function stops running we want to
also close that source file so that's
why we'll say differ Source file.
flows now we'll read all the plain
text from the source file so to read the
pl text from the source file we'll use
io. read all and source
file what you get back is plain
text and now we'll handle the error also
error is not equal to
n
banic now the password that you have you
want to store it in a variable because
we want to work with it so we'll say key
is equal to
password and and now we'll create an
empty nuns this is an empty nuns make
and it's a slice of bite and of 12
so it's going to look something like
this it'll be 0 comma 0 comma 0 right 0
0 0 till 12 so 12 different values all
of them zero that's what you create with
this now and now we will randomize the
nuns okay so we have created the empty
DS now we'll randomize it we'll put
random values in it and the way to do
that is we'll
say IO do
read full random.
reader so fill it with random values and
error is not equal to
nil Panic error
dot
awesome what's the next step now so on
my screen the next step is we pass all
these values to create into the password
based deration key derivation function
okay so the password based key
derivation function is available to us
in a package of the same name P key PB
KD F2 and that function we pass the key
the nuns 4096 as the number of
iterations 32 as a length and sha 1. new
as the
algorithm so if you look here we passing
the password to encrypt the file the
nuns the number of iterations sha one
and the B length which is 32 in our case
and this is the number of
vibrations what you get back from his
this is called as the derived key DK so
we just in short it's
DK this package that we're getting
everything from
is
is this package pbkdf2
so now we have the derived key now we
will
create we
will run it past by the advanced
encryption standard so we'll say a. new
Cipher
DK and we'll get the
block and we'll handle the error
also so let say if error is not equal to
n
Panic
error okay so we have this now the
cipher block and now we want to use the
galwa whatever ever it is you know GCM
I'll call it GCM so it's the new GCM
function so I'll say cipher. new GCM
function and I'll pass in the block and
what you get back is AES
GCM if error is not equal to nil Panic
error dot
error
okay so as as you know we did all these
steps to to be able to run the seal
function here which is what creates the
which is is what converts the pain text
to Cipher text so coming back here let
us use the AES
GCM do seal
[Music]
function this is what's going to take
the plain text for
us and
send back the cipher
text and
you uh append the
nuns so there is one thing that I have
not drawn here but I have actually
talked about it here is that we add the
12 by nuns at the end of the encrypted
file so we want to do that now we want
to append
the nuns to the cipher
text
and store that in the cipher text
itself so now we have the complete cyer
text now we want to create a
file source file for the encrypt data
and want to write the data to the source
file so what you'll do now is we'll call
it the destination
file.
create create that
file handle the error also here
panic and at the end of this function
when this function uh has done
processing you want to close this file
as
well so you have created the file now
you just want to write Cipher text into
that file so write the cipher text into
the file but this is the de file you'll
say destination file. light and you
will get the error if
any if error is not equal to
n
Panic
error
okay so this was our encrypt function so
far so good and as soon as I uh hit uh
save it got me all the packages that I
needed and now we want to work for the
decrypt uh function the decrypt function
is very similar it takes in
the the the the path of the file and the
password with the help of which we
will decrypt
this and first things first you want to
check if the file that to be decrypted
the the request that's coming for
decryption if the file even exists or
not so do the same thing
.at
Source this do is not
exist error and here you
will this is the error you're handling
here and you're just saying
Panic error okay and actually some of
the part from here is going to be
similar so I will just um copy this
part all of this part till here I'll
just copy
it uh once
again after
this so here you will have uh SRC file
where you'll open that source file and
at the end you will close it also and
here instead of plain text you'll just
have Cipher text because that's what is
in the file now because you have already
encrypted the file and you're passing
the encrypted file to this decrypt
function and that's why whatever is
there in the file is now Cipher text so
we have done in the decryption part we
we're done with this check for the
encrypted file open the encryp file and
read the text Cipher text from the
encrypted
file all of this is
done okay so the password that you will
receive in this function will again be
stored in the variable key then we'll
have a variable called salt which will
basically have Cipher text and length of
Cypher so without
the last
12 okay
and x dot and code to
string the salt which is basically the
nuns the last 12 is the nuns right
you'll have it inall in Sal and we will
use the hex package to decode this
string and we'll store that in Str
[Music]
Str sorry this will be NS
now
okay okay so what do you pass again in
that function the password based key
derivation function for decryption you
pass the same password to to that will
be used to decrypt the bite length 32
chart 1 iterations 4096 and the NS that
we got from the last 12 uh digits of the
cipher
text and the same thing you do here you
say new Cipher
sorry new yeah a. new Cipher and you
pass the derivation key derivative key
and you'll again get the
block and again you can have handle the
error if error not error not equal to
nil and then you want to pass that block
to uh the
cipher AES Cipher so what I'll do is
I'll yeah we've already done that and
now we want to pass it through the
CGM GCM sorry
yeah so the same thing that we done
there we're doing it here and now
there's only one little difference uh
which is that instead of using the as
GCM
do
um seal function we'll just use
a
GCM do open
function so here we'll have the nuns the
cipher
text which
is everything apart from those
last um
12 and what you get back from this is
the plain
text okay so what you're seeing now is
uh step by step we're just looking at
the
diagram and we are uh converting the
diagram into code okay so our flowchart
into
code again let's handle the error
here and then we'll again create the
file like we did last time the
destination
file so I'll copy and paste that part
Here and Now we will write plain text to
this file so instead here we wrote the
cipher text to the file and now we will
write the plain text which we have
received to the file so here what was
happening in the encrypt function what
was happening is that you ran that
function called uh the seal function
which gave you the cipher text to run
the seal function as GCM seal function
you had to uh do all of these steps
which is get the plain text and then
create your nuns have your password
ready uh create a derived key with PB
kdf function use Advanced encription
standard new Cipher create a block
Cipher block pass the cipher block uh
with GCM and get AES GCM and then you
were able to call the seal function to
get the cipher text with all those
values here exactly the same things you
just had to call the as GCM do open
function because this will give us the
plain text from the cipher text Cipher
text is everything apart from those 12
last digits which actually was the nuns
in our case for nuns right the salt
which we can convert into nuns here and
uh then finally just like we did in the
encryption file we created a file and
then we wrote plain text back into that
file and now when we open up this file
we'll be able to access it right so as
you can see I have a lot of errors and
I'm not at all scared because now when I
go ahead and run this program uh I
will come to know what the issues are so
I'll say go
run
encrypt
PNG and here I see all of these issues
it says uh file Crypt to add file Crypt
and yeah so xterm and file CPT are not
there that means I need to say go mod
tidy so first I'll get these
packages
let's I can see some issue there but
let's see if it still
works yeah still the same issues I'm
getting so let's try to fix
it now one issue out here obviously is
this part which is I've copied the link
from my previous project now this is
obviously my GitHub and this should be
the name of the project right and I'm
and I'm calling file Crypt package but
the name of the project is wrong that I
have to go and get from go mod so the
name of the project is actually go file
encryption in this case and I have to go
ahead and get it here and this issue
will go away uh now what we'll do is
we'll
again go and
run go run
encrypt IMG or PNG and now we'll get a
list of issues okay so now uh on line 68
file Crypt line 68 file
Crypt as I can see it's should have been
error okay now let me check out line um
83 line 83 key is not used yes because I
was supposed to use key here by mistake
I've written name and here also I can
see one more issue it's key should have
been key right uh now the other thing I
can
see is um
88 which is undefined yeah it's the same
thing this one the issue 988 all right
so that's solved but now I can still see
four issues in main. go so what we'll do
is we'll go ahead and run this
again uh
here now we can see some issues from
main.go file and the um first one is on
50 okay
and then online
66 and then on line
print line uh
102 right so what I'm trying to show you
here is with if you're working with
Technologies like goang and rust you
don't have to worry at all about making
mistakes the code so don't depend too
much on extensions right so many people
would tell you get extensions that help
you uh not make any mistakes in the code
while writing the code uh for spelling
and for for uh you know goang so don't I
would suggest don't don't depend too
much on that as you can see I I wrote
everything
myself and uh I just depended on the on
the goang compiler to tell me the issues
and I just solve them one by one so just
just depend on Goan compiler because
when you're in an interview when you're
giving the interview for some company uh
you're not sure what kind of environment
you'll get to write the code with mostly
it's an online environment right and you
have somebody on a call you have an
online environment and you have to write
the code in that online environment that
won't have the extensions that you want
and that you work with so it's highly
recommended that you don't depend on
extensions I've had many of my friends
get into a lot of trouble because of
that um but but know how to work with
the goang compiler a lot like get very
very good at debugging code okay so uh
now things should work so it says ask me
to enter the
password and I will enter the password
it will ask me to confirm the password
I'll confirm the password it say file
successfully protected try to open up
the file I'm not able to okay and now
what I'll do is I'll just run this um
again with instead of encrypt it be
decrypt and I'll just enter the password
I had Ed earlier and now as you can see
I can check out the file I can look at
the file okay so this was our project
everything works perfectly fine thank
you so much for watching uh this I would
say is is an intermediate level project
it's not very Advanced it's not very
simple uh like it's not a beginner level
project probably and it's not an
advanced project also somewhere uh in
the middle but I hope you learned a lot
thank you so much for watching if you
haven't subscribed to this channel make
sure you subscribe I'll come up with
awesome content like this in the future
thank you so much we're building
something really interesting in today's
video what we'll do is we'll just take
some plain text encrypt it we'll get the
encrypted text we'll then run it through
a decryption function and then we'll get
the decrypted text so it's quite
straightforward it's something we
haven't done before on this channel
right it's uh working with encryption
algorithms so we using a very simple
encryption algorithm called the C are
Cipher in this project and let me give
you a quick demo on how this works so if
I run go run main.
go my plain text that I had given to the
program was hello world and I get the
encrypted text which is c z g g jrj mg Y
and when we decrypt it again we get
Hello World back right and in the
program itself you can uh give it some
text that it will encrypt and decrypt
you can also build a CLI on top of it to
accept the text from the user I haven't
done that because in this project I want
us to focus only on the encryption and
decryption part we don't want to focus
on the CLI part because I've already
done that in many other projects okay so
how this is working is we first take
some text hello world right and by the
way uh this is very quick visual
programming visual planning that we'll
do before we actually start programming
so that we know exactly where we going
and this is just a quick demo to show
you how and uh how we're going to build
it and what exactly uh is it that we're
doing so we have our text hello world
that you saw in the demo and we give
this a key five so this key can change
could be seven could be 10 whatever but
in my case I'd given it the key five
okay and I'll I'll tell you what that
key
means so with Caesar Cipher what what
what happens is you pass in let's say
all the uh alphabets so in my case in my
program I had passed it all the
alphabets you can also pass in numbers
to this program and you can also give it
special characters and what we want to
do is with CES Cipher we want to replace
uh this text with some
other uh alphabets from the alphabets
that we we have given it right so this
one is going to be called as the
original
text because from this we will
select uh some
other
characters that will basically replace
this text of powers right so in the in
the end you get something like this is
CZ e jrj mg Y which is the encrypted
text which nobody can understand but
when you decrypt it the person who's
supposed to uh receive this will get
Hello World back
okay and by the way uh in the beginning
of computation this is how many
encryption algorithms worked and now you
have obviously much more advanced
algorithms and that's what you see when
you see WhatsApp saying it's end to end
encrypted they're basically encrypting
all the text that you're sending and
you're getting back uh the user is
getting back the actual text but then
there's some encryption happening in
between so that nobody can intercept
those messages and read the meaning or
read those messages basically so um the
way this is working is first we'll take
26 which is the length of all of these
uh all of the basically characters that
we have sent the original text length is
26 and then we'll subtract the key which
is five from that okay and then we'll
create two different uh versions of this
original text one is from 0 to 21
because if you subtract 26 from 25 you
get the number 21 so from 0 to 21 you'll
separate that into a different bucket
and from 21 to 26 you'll separate that
into a different bucket right and then
what you do is you attach this in front
of uh this part right so the one from 21
to 26 you attach that in front of this
these remaining uh digits or the
remaining uh alphabets or letters and
you get something like this this is
something called as the hash
text hash text and essentially what you
have to do now is you have to take H and
find a uh corresponding or an equivalent
um letter from here that will basically
replace H okay so how do you do that
first what you do is you find the index
of H in the the original letters so you
go to the original letters which is the
original text and you find the index of
H so it's a b c d e f g h this H this is
H here it's the number is seven so
that's the index of H in original
letters which is seven and then you
apply this formula this formula
basically gives you the uh this this
formula will give you the result of the
index of the uh the
corresponding uh alphabet that you have
to pick up from this particular text the
hash textt right so so you get i'll
repeat again you get the
um the position or the index of uh that
number that you want to encrypt from the
original text and then you run a formula
and you get this is the main formula for
cyer Cipher uh Cipher algorithm and then
you get the position or the index of the
uh alphabet in the hash text and that's
the one that you want to replace this
with so uh in the hash text right so
firstly let's run the formula so the
formula basically says the position in
the original uh text of H which is 7
plus the length of the original letters
which is 26 and uh modulus with the
length of the original letters which is
again 26 and the answer that you get
here is basically uh 7even so uh in in
our case uh the index of H and original
letter of seven and the index of uh uh
the the index from the formula that we
got by running the formula is again 7 so
we have to look for the seventh alphabet
in the hash text so it's like 1 2 3 4 5
6 and then 7 7 is B in our case right as
you can see B so we replace H by B and
similarly you can run e which is hello
world right that's the text we want to
encrypt so e you take e and then you do
the same same thing and what you get is
e will be replaced by Z right so Z is
and how that happens is because in the
original text uh e is the fifth digit
right so when you when you run this
formula again you'll get five here and
when you uh go to the fifth digit here 1
2 3 4 5 Z is the fifth one so that's why
you say five and now you don't even have
to run the formula you can just get all
the other digits very easily because L
is the 12th right so if you go to the
original text so L is the 12th so it's 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 L is the 12th
and that's why in the hash text also you
will also look at the 12th uh alphabet
or the 12th letter so it's 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 which is in our case it's G so
that's why both the L's have been shown
as G out here okay then you can get the
others also really easily and this is
how basically this entire um algorithm
is working now this is very predictable
like uh if you give this to somebody and
they figure out uh like the
corresponding of H and E for example in
this they can easily figure out all the
other letters and this is a very very
simple uh encryption to break it doesn't
take a lot of brains to uh to break this
encryption so that's why this is like
the simplest simplest encryption uh that
I wanted to show you and then you've
seen my other videos on on the
blockchains and how we've used Shard 256
right to encrypt and they those uh more
advanced algorithms have more advanced
properties you have the Avalanche effect
and you have uh uh what's the other term
I'm forgetting the term it's basically
but but the property is that
no particular letter corresponds to
another letter another letter right so
that property is called something I'm
forgetting the name right now but the
Avalanche effect again is that if you
change one thing in that encryption
everything uh the complete uh signature
changes so you have those Advanced
properties that you get with Advanced
algorithms you you don't have any
properties with this is like very
straightforward uh this this has existed
from the time of Caesar I think that's
why it's called Caesar Cipher it's like
Way Beyond way before um
the the invention of computers but it's
a great algorithm to know it's it's
great to get started with it encryption
and it's a great project to build with
goang because we'll work with uh this
this little algorithm but we'll also get
to apply our goang Concepts and that's
what what will make us a better goang
developer okay so with this out of the
way let's get started now before we get
started I just want to tell you that
this particular uh video will be part of
the 47 killer goang projects CD so I
have this playlist on my uh channnel it
has 47 projects in goang so in case you
didn't know that you want to check you
might want to check them out uh so this
47 will now become 48 because this video
will will be there in that and what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to arrange
these videos in the level of difficulty
where some some of them I've not still
not arranged them in the right order but
I will do that and then eventually they
will be in the right order of difficulty
and you want to start from the beginning
and start building projects uh one by
one all right that's how you want to go
about these now the next thing I want to
tell you is is that we have this Discord
server for my YouTube and everyone is
allowed here and we discuss really
awesome stuff uh like you know what
we're learning today and we're having a
lot of discussions so like let's say if
you have any goang issues you can come
here and post the issues um and we we're
discussing about any issues about goang
you know I I help quite a bit on this
community so if you if you want you can
join it all you have to do is the the
link I think is out here so you have to
just go here and this is I think the
link for joining the community if you're
not able to join it let me know I'll uh
I'll make sure I'll send the new link
with you okay so that's one more thing I
want to share with you and the code for
this particular project and all the
other projects is on my GitHub so in
case I don't share my GitHub link with
you you have to know it's Akil Sharma 90
on GitHub and you'll find almost all of
the projects here this is the one that
we're building today sorry not this one
this is the one that we're building
today simple encryption decryption with
goang using Cesar Cipher right so the
code is already there uh all you have to
do is just come here and uh in case you
get stuck you just have to refer to that
code all right so everything is uh clear
now now what we have to do is we have to
um I will
just go back to my
um the the place where I keep all my
goang projects and I will just create a
new directory I'll just say go um
encryption YT
okay and I
will CD into it and here we will go mod
in
it and I'll just github.com
[Music]
ail Sharma
SLO
encryption
y so what this does for for us is it
creates a go. mod file which will have
the list of all the modules that we use
in this particular project we're not
using uh any third party modules I think
mostly so you don't need to worry too
much about it but still we'll just have
it uh in any case here I'll just create
the main.go
file and this is a very small
straightforward project there's not a
lot of uh Engineering in this but uh
it's it's small and straightforward like
I said and uh it's a great project to
build like great uh beginner level
project to build so in my main go file
I'll just say package main which is the
first thing you write anyways in your
main. go file and then I'll have some
import related stuff right so I'll have
I'll just write import here and
accordingly I'll import the stuff that I
want to import I'll have uh the main
function obviously Funk
Main and here is where I will Define my
plain
text which in my case is hello world you
can change it
also and then I'm going to print it out
I'm going to print out the plain text as
it happened in our demo also right same
way plain text and we print we print out
plain text then we have our
encrypted text which is uh what we're
going to get when we call our encrypt
function that we will create now so
we'll create an encrypt function it will
take in the key in my case will be five
and the plain text right so this means
that here up here somewhere will be our
encrypt function so it'll say funk
encrypt and it will take the key which
is the integer and the plain text sorry
PL text which will be string and this
will return to us the result which will
be the string the encrypted text
obviously right and then obviously uh
apart from the encryption function if we
have an inun function we also need the
decryption function this will again take
in the key the
encrypted text
and it's going to return back to result
which is the string so once you've
encrypted it you have this uh in this
variable called encrypted and we will
print it out first so we say I can do a
print
Len and encrypted text will be
encrypted and then we have decrypted is
equal
topt five
comma
um and then we'll print it
out
decrypted
come on
decrypt so to the decrypted decrypt
function you are passing the key and the
encrypted text and you'll get that in
the decrypted uh variable and then we'll
just print that out so that's it that's
all our Funk name is doing okay at the
top I will say my
original letter will have all the 26 a b
c d e f g h j k l m n p q r s t u v x y
z
okay so original will have all of this
original letter basically
means this the original text this has
all of the uh letters this is the plain
text and this is the key five which
we've passed okay now we want the hash
text so for the hash text we need
another function let's call
it frun hash letter
function takes in the key takes in the
uh original letter it'll take in the
original letter and we'll say result and
string okay now here the first function
that's called is the encrypt function so
we'll start building upon the encrypt
function so as you remember in the
encryption part the first thing we do is
is we first want this right and then
we'll find the index of H the first
letter we'll start we'll start letter by
letter the first letter which is H we'll
find the position of H in the original
text but we also want this right you
want the hash text because after we run
our formula we want to find the uh that
particular index what's the value at
that index in our hash
text so that's why we need this also
first so well we'll call the hash letter
function so we'll say
hash letter function we'll pass it the
key and the original letter original
letter being
this we'll just pass it
there and to start with we'll say V hash
string isal to empty now hash string is
what you want to return from here so
there this result that we sending back
is the hash string and one by one you
will keep adding to this uh empty string
some values so for example for H the
first value in our case as you saw here
uh we'll get C right so whatever we get
here C and z and G so one by when we'll
keep adding values to it we'll run
things through a loop and we'll keep
appending things to this hash string uh
and that's why first we'll start with
this being empty and then we will run
um actually at the end here we will will
have this function called strings. map
and we say find one comma plane text so
strings. map what this does is it takes
in uh the plane text
okay in our case the plain text is
actually hello world so it takes in
hello world and one by one it'll send it
and call this function called find one
so it'll take uh H first and then e e
next L lse we'll take all these things
one by one strings. and then call the
find one uh you know function so what is
find one so find
one is equal to a function it's a
function which takes in r as a rune and
returns a rune now what does that mean
so
Rune help so runes basically help you um
with unicodes so what we're saying here
is that um a run represents a single uni
code character okay so for example a the
value of a is 65 so you get the ask2
value and now you can uh work with the
letters in a much more flexible way so
you get separation between all these
letters so for example A B C D E F
because you're sending them one by one
but then with run you're able to work
with them in like much more easily uh
because
here what we have not covered is is that
the runes that you'll
get here also you'll use Rune to be able
to work with that so we'll be using run
basically all throughout to be able to
uh iterate over all these letters and
work with those letters uh and then
perform operations on that so it'll take
in our run so for each uh letter like H
we take each letter from the pr text
which is like the hello world right so H
we take that and we send it to find one
and then what the find one function is
doing is it's taking in that H and
returning us to us the equivalent letter
uh in the in the encrypted text so in
our case it will be C now how do we get
from H to C let's take a
look so uh first I think I'll just build
the hash letter function because
otherwise there will be just confusions
because you know I wanted to explain the
Run Part before we wrote Rune here
because we using it in the hash function
so I didn't do that uh my bad but I
think I'll just build this function
before we work more on the encrypt
function so that it just makes more
sense so this hash letter function right
all it's supposed to do is it's supposed
to um take in this key and then divide
this into from a to Zu and from V to Z
divide uh the original text into these
two parts and then also put this in
front of this and then return that part
that's so we want to return the hash
text from this function so we'll say
last
letter key equal to
string
runes length of letter letter being
original letter in our case so from here
to here the length is obviously 26 so
we'll say length of letter minus key to
length of letter so this is Runes
of 21 is to 26 so from 21 to 26 what are
the things which is in our case v sorry
2126 v
w now x y z so these five things will
basically come in the last letter key
and then we'll say the left over letters
left left
over letters letter is equal
to
string
runes and
zero length of
letter
minus okay so 0 to 21 so this is length
of letter which is 26 minus ke which is
key is 5 so it becomes 21 so 0 to 21
will come in
uh one place like I said and 21 to 26
will come in another place so this has 0
to 21 and this has 21 to 26 so last
letter three and the left over letters
now all we have to do is we have to
return I told you right we'll return
This plus this so we'll return the uh
last
letter and followed by the leftover
letters so let's do that so we'll say
FMP
Dot
Sprint
F here let's say percentage s and
percentage
s comma last
letter two comma left
over
letters so we able to return what we
promised from this function which is the
string which is the hashed uh
the hash text from this
function so in the encrypt function we
were now in the find one function and
here we will first start with the
positional strings. index why the
position uh if you remember I had told
you that what we'll do is we'll find the
index of H or the position of H and the
original letters That's How we'll get
seven right so this is the original text
and we have to Now find the index of H
there since strings. index and the
original letter comma string and that
there will be uh
run
R and now we'll get the position of that
letter now uh if what if the original
text that we passed original letter text
that we passed somehow we forgot to
write there was a type of we forgot to
write H
there right then Position will basically
become min-1 and that's what we want to
check for so we want to check if
position is not equal to minus1 that
means the letter that you want to
encrypt is actually existing in the
original letter you want to find the
position if it's not equal to minus one
then we can do something about it
otherwise it's a problem right other you
just want to return the same thing
return
R um and finally from here we want to
return the hashed string as you know
hash string which is now empty we want
want to fill it up so if everything is
all right and it's not uh minus one then
we'll say
letter
position is equal
to position plus
length original
letter percentage length of orig
letter and hash
string
Hash Hash
string plus
string hash
letter letter position okay so what's
happening here
is we first find the position and then
we uh run our modulus function so if you
remember I told you the function or the
formula looks something like this where
we add the position plus the length of
the original letters and we mod we run
mod modul which is length of position
dat so in our case be 7 + 26 modulus of
26 you get 7 right so that's what we're
doing here so you get the letter of the
position uh which is seven and now the
next step would be to look for that uh
letter which is at the seventh position
in the hashed text and that's what we're
doing
so we're looking in the hash letter that
we have hash letter hash text we passing
this letter position and getting that
particular value converting into string
and adding that to Hash string so each
each of these values from the plain text
one by one because of the help of
strings. map one by one we'll take it
like H and e and l and O and then we'll
pass it to find one find one is
accepting it as a rune and also
returning a rune in our case and then
it's
um adding everything to hashed string
that's what's happening adding
everything to Hash
string finally we'll have as string that
that's what we'll return from this
function okay now the decrypt function
is going to be the exact opposite of
this the decrypt function is going to
basically um have
same method which is calling the hash
letter
function and we'll capture that value in
a variable
called hash letter so the hash function
will pass the key and the original
letter and again you'll start with the
hash string which is
entty so with the with the
decryption we have to uh find
again you know that value in the
um in the hash letter index so let's so
this is what we'll start with okay in
the beginning and we we'll find the
value of let's say
C so in in the in the encryption we
started with the original text now we'll
start with the hash text so let me write
it here this is
decryption
sorry you start with the hash text and
you see that the uh hge right is of
particular value
and
um and this is the original text
here yeah so like I was saying this will
happen before so we'll first check the
value of that uh you know letter here
let's say in our case C right so we'll
notice the value is 5 6 7 uh 8 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 so this will be eight in our case
right and then then that eight we have
to find in the uh in the hashed text
sorry the sorry in the in the original
text so the original text is different
right
it's so decryption will exactly be the
opposite of encryption so an encryption
we first found the position of the value
in the original text and then found an
equivalent in the hash text and
decryption will be completely opposite
we'll first find the position of that
particular um
so C for example we'll first find the
value of that letter in our hash text in
this case C and then with that position
we'll run that formula again and we'll
get some value and then that value we
have to pick from the original text and
that's how we'll get back uh hello world
from this text so that's the entire
method that we have to follow now okay
so let's do that so for encryption for
decryption we say hash string is
completely empty and then we say find
find
one and who's going to call find one
um out here we'll just say strings.
maap find one comma encrypted
text and
return hash Str right so the other thing
that's changing here is that with uh
with encrypt we sent the plain text to
our find one but in decryption uh we're
passing the encrypted text to our find
one function and then find the F final
function we'll say funk R Rune and Rune
okay so that that was one change which
is passing plain text versus passing
enry text the other change which I was
showing you in the diagram was that we
will find the position of the uh of the
the the word in this hashed letters so
earlier we found it in the original
letters right the first position now
we'll find it in the hash letter and
we'll say
string
run
R and again we'll check for the same
thing position uh is not equal to minus
one check for the same
thing from here we'll go
R yeah this if you remember we checking
because that that uh particular value
that's coming in here needs to be there
in the hashed text right so not the
original letter in this case is the hash
letter so it has to be there in the hash
letter the position otherwise will be
one minus one so only if it's not minus
one we can uh proceed and this is how
we'll proceed so we'll say
letter
[Music]
position equal to You'll again apply the
formula plus length of original
letter
percentage length
of original
letter which is mod modular and then
origal letter and we'll say hashed
string equal to Hash
string plus string and original
letter letter
sorry letter
position
forgot the return are
here
okay right so uh main main differences
in decrypt and encrypt is like I said
we're passing the encrypted text here
we're passing the plane text there and
here we check cheing for the position in
the hash letter hash letter being this
one and here uh in the encryption we
were checking for the letter position
the original original text original
letter here for finding the letter
position formula we again we use the
length of original letter only that's
not that's not different that's the same
thing and finding the hash string
finally at the end we found here from
the the hash letter we found the
equivalent text and now to Crypt it back
we finding it from the original letter
the equivalent uh you know letter so
here we'll get the back to decrypt
decrypted
text now uh I don't see any issues and
or any errors here in the in the code so
what I'll do is I'll just go here and
I'll just say go run main. for so if
there are any errors we'll get them here
but there were not any errors luckily so
we had our PL text we got the encrypted
text and we got the decrypted text okay
so I'll just quickly go over it again in
case you missed anything uh we started
with our plain
text we uh got the encrypted
text which is this we sent it to the
decryption function got the decrypted
text started with Hello World text we
want to replace each single letter uh
with with different alphabet the key
that we passed was five and the original
text we pass was this so this can have
numbers this can have small characters
also this can have special characters
also
and when we pass the key as five we run
this through the original text through a
hash hash function which basically
subtracts five from the length of the
original text so we get 21 so we divide
the original text into two different
parts one is from 0 to 21 and from 21 to
26 then we pass the hash text back so
which is this uh before the uh before
this text and we pass this back to the
function in the encryption function the
first thing we do is we find the index
of the first letter which is H in the
original uh text so in this case we get
seven now we run our formula which is
position plus length of original letters
percentage or modul length of original
letters and then we get again uh 7even
and we find seven in the hashed text
because we want to convert from original
to the hash or the enry encrypted we'll
find an or uh like a like a
corresponding uh digit or letter from
here
and B so we found that H is equal to B
Because B is on the seventh position
after we ran this formula and that's how
from Hello World we actually got this in
this description it works the completely
opposite because you find the position
of
C
in first in the hash text and then we
get that position and then we basically
run it through the formula and then we
get the original uh text
sorry and and yeah and we get the
position in the original text of that
corresponding letter in this case it
will be H now guys uh there's one thing
that I have uh you know made a small
mistake in right and I want you to to uh
find that out in case you haven't
figured out in the whole program one
thing that I've been missing or and
messing up with uh just so so that you
know uh in case youve understood it
please let me know where I've made that
mistake uh there'll be basically ensure
so if you if you go through the video
again look for the mistake things will
become much clearer to you and you'll be
able to um completely understand this
concept right so let me know if you
found that
mistake uh I'm going to tell you the
answer anyways if if in case if you have
not found it so the mistake is that the
value uh the actual position of H is not
seven it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 it's actually
eight not seven
so that's why you have to write here
eight and you have to write
here8 you have to write here
eight then have write here
8 and should have in C right H should be
equal to C and not
b and that's how you get C right here
right so I made that
mistake um and now you can actually go
and run the actual values and you'll see
everything is consistent all right so
that's
perfect I hope you were paying attention
now when you looked at the mistake uh
everything will make
sense right so
um so what I want you to do is I want
you to uh run through uh the entire code
once again and run through those values
once again so that you basically
internalize whatever I've taught you uh
try try to put different values here
like smaller text and then special text
characters all of that try and and see
uh how that works and thank you so much
for watching this video uh I hope you
will join our community on Discord where
we'll get to hang out and you'll watch
all the other videos in this
um in the uh in the in the goang
playlist all right so thank you so much
and I'll see you in the next video